un pomeriggio
siamo quasi alla fine perché dovreste
fare giochi oggi provo a raccontarvelo
incomincio facendoci facendo di vedere
il primo videogioco che abbia mai
giocato che si chiama steroid forse
qualcuno di voi lo conosce e questo
gioco per me è molto interessante per
due motivi il primo motivo è lo spazio
lo spazio era una cosa che nei bambini
degli anni ottanta adoravamo perché
forse venivamo da un epoca in cui ancora
l'esplorazione spaziale era un qualcosa
di nuovo di emozionante un'avventura
verso mondi ignoti sconosciuti
oggi è un po ritornata però c'è stato un
periodo piuttosto lungo in cui non si
parlava di esplorazione spaziale e poi
un'altra cosa che sono le luci colorate
l'informatica il computer
questo e tron questo è un film di disney
straordinario incidentalmente negli anni
ottanta disney è riuscita a fare un film
in cui parlava della figura del game
designer di qualcuno che crea dei mondi
artificiali all'interno di un computer e
questa volta interessante e mi ha
portato a chiedere insistentemente i
miei genitori che mi regalassero un
computer e questo è il risultato il
primo computer che abbia mai avuto
avrà avuto sette otto anni lo spectrum e
con la spectrum ho cominciato a pensare
adesso posso creare anch'io questi mondi
beh non era così facile
il primo gioco che ho creato non ve lo
posso far vedere perché non c'era la
tecnologia per catturare le schermate
allora prove lo posso raccontare era un
semplice test di riflessi che hanno
chiamato ninja test perché oltre allo
spazio quell epoca dono molto di moda
anche i ninja e quindi ninja e questo è
stato il mio primo gioco e l'ho fatto
con con lo spectrum e mi sono reso conto
che fare queste cose era molto difficile
poi è venuto fuori e dungeons dragons e
con dungeons and dragons
mi sono trovato subito a mio agio perché
ti permetteva di creare dei mondi e
farli giocare i tuoi amici semplicemente
disegnando le mappe disegnando tutto
quello che c'era su un foglio di carta
che poi a game design è esattamente
quello che fa un game designer
all'inizio per lo meno e non era
necessario utilizzare il digitale e la
cosa divertente è che c'erano i draghi
sera la magia che era un'altra cosa che
in quel periodo ne va molto di moda
oltre allo spazio ai ninja così beh
possiamo dire che i giochi i videogiochi
in particolare hanno in qualche modo
hanno segnato alla mia esistenza e sono
il mio mezzo di intrattenimento
preferito quindi giochi i giochi sono
fantastici sono a cosa meravigliosa e
col passare del tempo la tecnologia li
ha fatti diventare sempre più belli
sempre più emozionanti sempre più
realistici carichi di diversità di
immaginazione è davvero così perché poi
a volte si scopre che quello che ti
dicono le pubblicità non è sempre vero
dal 2001 al 2012 questa l'evoluzione
della serie di halo io non ci vedo poi
così tanta immaginazione soltanto un
pochino di evoluzione tecnologica
probabilmente anche trascurabile
e i protagonisti dei giochi sono sempre
la stessa persona sempre uguali sempre
loro sempre un signore di 30 anni con i
capelli castani simpatico faccia
scassata eccetera eccetera molto
hollywood dove sono finite queste cose
io quando ero piccolo fine anni ottanta
c'era questo gioco era una roba
fantastica c'era questo gioco in cui tu
eri un mago imprigionato dentro una
sfera che doveva fare gli incantesimi
raccogliendo delle gocce di colore in un
mondo completamente surreale
questa è un immaginazione straordinaria
eppure non c'è più non non si trova più
così facilmente
per che cosa è successo è successo che
gli investimenti per creare un
videogioco se non ventati tantissimi
si rivolgono a un pubblico ampio e anno
sotto una tecnologia parecchio complessa
e questo fa sì che le grandi aziende
debbano per forza a limitare i rischi
come fanno a limitare i rischi vengono
sempre alle stesse persone che sanno che
reagiscono in un certo modo i giochi
queste persone sono invariabilmente
maschi teenager eterosessuali cheese
gender bianchi non c'è nessun tipo di
diversità nel target dei giochi e questo
fa sì che noi abbiamo un territorio
vastissimo universo praticamente
infinito di immaginazione e ne abbiamo
esplorato su un lato piccolissimo però
le cose hanno iniziato a cambiare da un
po di anni a questa parte
intendo per esempio ha preso di peso la
complessità della tecnologia che il
controller la semplificato e ha cercato
di dire ok voi vi siete portati la
console a casa l'avete messa nel salotto
però la console non è accessibile noi
cerchiamo di renderla più accessibile a
tutti perché ci dovete giocare con tutta
la famiglia ma ancora di più sono
arrivati gli smartphone e gli smartphone
sono finiti nelle tasche di tutte le
persone persone che non avevano mai
visto un videogioco vita loro e però ci
hanno messo dentro anche i videogiochi e
questo fatto si che un pubblico sempre
più vasto iniziasse ad accedere a queste
cose e poi anno è successo a uno ancora
più straordinaria i videogiochi sono
diventati parte di una mostra permanente
al museum of modern art di new york sono
stati considerati a te sono stati
considerati pezzi di umanità che vale la
pena fare vedere incidentalmente
guardate uno dei giochi che è in mostra
non ha per niente a che fare con sparare
in faccia agli alieni chissà come mai
e allora la gente ha iniziato a fare
cose diverse con i giochi a creare
giochi diversi dal solito e ci sono un
po di casi interessanti per esempio
proprio proteus cosa fa e chi è un
signore inglese che vive nelle mie blend
inglesi in mezzo alla campagna in un
posto meraviglioso e cosa ha fatto ha
creato questo mondo che tu esplori e
questo mondo reagisce semplicemente al
fatto che tu ci cammini in mezzo
reagisce con la musica
e dice con degli animali che si muovono
reagisce con dei cambiamenti nel
panorama
la cosa particolare di questo gioco e
avere preso il linguaggio degli
sparatutto in prima persona e averlo
completamente stravolto è uno sparatutto
in prima persona in cui tu non puoi
sparare non puoi saltare puoi solo
sederti a contemplare il panorama oppure
some self in south self robin arnott
prende le persone e le fa sdraiare sopra
ci sono dei microfoni e le fa parlare i
microfoni prendono la loro voce
la trasformano in immagini e suoni
creando un'esperienza rilassante e
condivisa o ancora il rapporto con
l'arte i pin bar uno studioso di game
design neozelandese che adesso sta a
malta ha preso la installazione la
performance di marina abramovic al moma
the artist is present e l'ha ricostruita
interamente all'interno in videogioco
con tanto di kodak di fare in tempo
reale 5 ore 6 ore di coda perché ci
vuole tanto si arriva davanti a marina
abramovic ti guarda in silenzio poi te
ne vai
questa è l'installazione è
un'installazione famosissima vinto un
sacco di premi e marina abramovic giorno
alza il telefono chiama più pin bar e
gli dice mi piace quello che hai fatto
facciamo dei giochi artistici insieme o
ancora diventano oggetti personali
questa disforia di hunan troppi hunan
troppi in questo gioco prende il
linguaggio dei giochi simbolici degli
anni 80 prendete tris prende space
invaders supermario li rielabora e li
utilizza per raccontare la disforia cioè
quella particolare quello stato che
attraversa il corpo umano nel momento in
cui sia attraverso una terapia ormonale
per il cambio di sesso e quindi racconta
una cosa difficile con un linguaggio
completamente diverso a quello che siamo
abituati o depresso in quest in
depressione quest joey queen prende
addirittura la depressione e la racconta
racconta come affrontarla attraverso un
gioco c'è chi si spinge ancora più in là
e raccontasse
adesso in maniera astratta ma nello
stesso tempo concreta trasformando un
ipad in un qualcosa che vuole essere
soddisfatto e risponde alle sue
sollecitazioni e il caso di luxuria
superga dei tail of tales oppure si
parla di problemi enormi a livello
mondiale
lucas pop ha creato recentemente papers
please in paper spesi il giocatore sta
alla frontiera e deve decidere chi far
entrare e alla frontiera però di uno
stato totalitario che giorno dopo giorno
rende i regolamenti per l'immigrazione
sempre più stringenti e questa persona
si trova ad avere a che fare con una
parata di umanità sempre diversa e
sempre più particolare e questo gli ha
permesso di raccontare quello che noi
facciamo quando controlliamo le
frontiere il senso che hanno le
frontiere e la differenza del controllo
e frontiere tra uno stato totalitario e
uno stato democratico che giocando a
questo gioco ci si rende conto
non è così tanto oppure ritornando nel
mondo del non digitale si prende un
determinato tipo di gioco in questo caso
i giochi da tavolo sui treni che sono
tanto cari alla popolazione tedesca e
gli adorano
sono anche molto belli è il caso di
train di brenda numero che prende questo
tipo di gioco cambia i materiali cambia
alcuni significati e fa una simulazione
di quello che succedeva durante
l'olocausto quando gli ebrei venivano
deportati nei campi di lavoro ed è un
gioco non si può comprare non è non è un
gioco in vendita un gioco che lei fa
girare per le fiere vi può garantire una
persona che ci ho giocato che è
estremamente toccante allora tutte
queste persone cosa hanno fatto
non si sono accontentate della scatola
dello spazio in cui sono chiusi i giochi
e hanno cominciato a esplorare lo spazio
profondo esplorare quel territorio
inesplorato che c'è bisogno di scoprire
e questo ha un effetto collaterale cioè
che la categoria del gamer come dice
molto bene lei fa l'ex
perché una bravissima giornalista di
settore è crollata è finita perché noi
non possiamo essere definiti da una
passione che abbiamo quella di giocare
tutti chi più chi meno giochiamo e i
giochi devono essere di tutti devono
essere per tutti ma soprattutto i giochi
devono poter essere fatti da tutti
perché tutti possono voler usare questo
mezzo espressivo come si fa ci sono
degli strumenti che ci aiutano per
esempio questo si chiama twine ed è uno
strumento che permette di creare dei
giochi come repression quest che abbiamo
visto prima cioè dei giochi basati sul
testo in cui si sceglie una possibilità
tra tante e si va avanti in una storia
in una storia wine non richiede nessuna
dote di programmazione si prende è tutto
visuale e si costruisce semplicemente
oppure stencil per esempio stencil che è
derivato da un altro linguaggio
sviluppato alle mitiche si chiama
scratch e permette di programmare il
comportamento dei vari elementi di gioco
semplicemente come un puzzle cioè
mettendo insieme i vari pezzi che hanno
delle caratteristiche per cui si si
connettono soltanto concerti altri pezzi
e questo ti permette tra l'altro di
capire come i vari pezzi fondamentali
della programmazione interagiscono tra
loro stencil a un ottimo modo per
imparare a programmare e andando più sul
complesso game maker studio è un gioco
che principale scusate un tool che
principalmente veniva utilizzato
soltanto da gli hobbisti oggi è
utilizzato anche per creare giochi
commerciali e comunque molto semplice da
approcciare e poi il grande protagonista
di questi tempi nel mondo di chi
sviluppa videogiochi che a unity unity a
un motore 3d vuol dire che permette di
creare dei mondi addirittura in tre
dimensioni e di fargli esplorare alle
persone che è un po la realizzazione del
sogno che avevo io da bambino a quello
che volevo fare finalmente adesso ci
riesco in maniera un po più semplice
perché dovremmo fare questa cosa qua beh
innanzitutto per migliorare il mondo dei
giochi paolo pedercini che è un
bravissimo game designer è un attivista
che lavora in negli stati uniti insegna
anche che il design ha detto a un
recente game for change che i giochi il
prossimo passo per i giochi non dovrà
essere un passo tecnologico l'abbiamo
visto l'evoluzione tecnologica
poi alla fine non ha prodotto tutte
queste differenze ma invece cercare di
far entrare più persone possibili nella
pratica del game design perché abbiamo
bisogno di altre idee abbiamo bisogno di
esploratori di persone che provino a
fare cose diverse in qualche modo gli fa
eco il presidente americano obama che in
un discorso alle scuole ha esortato i
ragazzi piuttosto che andare a comprare
un gioco fate un gioco perché quelle
capacità che gli servono per fare un
gioco sono esattamente le capacità che
un sacco di aziende stanno cercando la
capacità di programmare di risolvere
problemi il problem solving è una delle
nostre capacità che il fare giochi
esercita di più perché fare ciò che è
una cosa complessa e richiede tantissima
risoluzione di problemi continua però è
anche avvincente questo perché fare
giochi un po come giocarli e quindi
entrano in gioco cose simpatiche come
questa che è un neurotrasmettitore che è
la dopamina che è quel
neurotrasmettitore che viene emesso dal
cervello nel momento in cui noi abbiamo
un senso di vittoria sulle avversità
trionfi amo sulle avversità ed è una
cosa che noi ricerchiamo costantemente
perché ci piace da matti
incidentalmente i neuro scienziati
dicono che questa roba qua è quella che
ci ha fatto evolvere dall'essere un po
più di scimmie a diventare persone che
costruiscono palazzi ai arrivano nello
spazio quindi direi che è abbastanza
importante essere amici della dopamina
ora molti di voi diranno ok va bene
questo mi sta dicendo tutte queste cose
però poi io come vedi vendo i giochi
la verità è che non avete bisogno di
vendere i vostri giochi la verità che
giochi sono un mezzo espressivo è
esattamente come la scrittura come il
disegno voi potete prendere e creare un
gioco esclusivamente per voi metterlo in
un cassetto e non farlo mai vedere a
nessuno
oppure come fanno i blogger prendete il
gioco e lo fate vedere un sacco di
persone
magari non lo vendete non è importante
questo l'importante è il viaggio
l'importante è aver esplorato qualcosa
di nuovo e avere scoperto un mezzo
espressivo nuovo quindi per concludere
box
fate un gioco però fatelo così fate in
modo che sia personale che ci sia
qualcosa di voi dentro fate in modo che
sia diverso non rifatte halo non ce ne
frega più niente di sparare in faccia
agli alieni vogliamo di nuovo i maghi
dentro la palla queste robe qua diverse
fate in modo che sia accessibile perché
ci sono tantissime persone che non hanno
nessuna voglia di prendere in mano in
coso con 18 pulsanti e capire quale
cavolo di pulsante devo schiacciare
adesso potete fare un gioco con un tasto
solo l'ha fatto un signore gioco si
chiama canabalt ci ho fatto un sacco di
soldi e questo è tutto qui ci sono i
miei riferimenti se volete scrivere
insultare non risultare no per favore
che già nel mondo dei giochi questa roba
terribile e il mio twitter handle se
volete buttare
grazie